hey everybody welcome back to the making
of planet coaster in the last episode I
showed you mostly how I made the planet
itself and that's almost finished at
this point so in this episode I'll talk
mostly about some of the tricks that are
used in the game to create the illusion
that this is an actual planets floating
out there in space and the first one was
to make a building that is upside down
and I don't think this has been tried
before in the game I at least I haven't
seen it it's just something that I
needed to do because I wanted to have
two consoles on both sides of the planet
and obviously one console would be just
standing upright and the other course
would have to be upside down which was
the easiest way to go about doing this
but still it was my first time trying
anything like this so the basic way that
I decided to go about doing this is to
build the entire building out of mostly
walls which more or less function in the
same way I have upside down as they do
regularly and the same goes for some of
these flat roof pieces but the real
challenge was to get some upside down
roof pieces in here so the roof pieces
are more or less most of them are
actually made custom I just put a bunch
of blanks together and make the shapes
that I needed out of that to make this
entire upside-down structure and that is
really where the entire illusion is
coming from it's not too hard to make
it's really in the pieces then you have
to make upside down because you can't
rotate them that I had to make my custom
pieces but they decide this is actually
surprisingly easy to do I saw a lot of
comments debating whether I made a
blueprint of a building and then pasted
the blueprints entering the blueprint
upside down but there's no way you can
possibly do that I wasn't able to do any
in-game tricks or shady tricks or
anything like that it's just custom
objects being put into such a way that
it looks as if they're actually upside
down roof elements same kind of goes for
the battlements because I didn't want to
have some battlements around this thing
so instead of taking the endgame
battlements which you can't actually put
upside down because the roof pieces I
just decided to make my own and for most
of these things like the windows you
just kind of slap them onto the balls
upside down and that's pretty much
it sits in the end looking back at it
it's really not that impressive but at
the time it was kind of hard sometimes
to figure it all out because I didn't
plan it no pun intended but um
eventually I suppose it's not actually
that hard you might also notice that
there's a very big contrast in a way
that this planet or this building is
compared to the top building since I
didn't want to go into any roofs that
are dome shaped or very intricate or
complicated to build since I had to
build upside down so most of the roofs
and the general structure of the
building on the dark side is actually
very jagged and it's very pointed
because I have to keep it quite simple
and not use too many pieces so this
building has a very pointy roof and a
very pointy spire whereas the building
on top of the planet has that domed roof
and a lot more round shapes and things
like that which was kind of
unintentional because you know doing the
pointy spire here is just a lot easier
than modeling a dome upside down like
making a dome regularly is already quite
hard but making one that's upside down
and just kind of felt like I wasn't
looking forward to that kind of
challenge so I figured not to do that
but I think in the end also it does work
quite well because there's definitely a
contrast between these two buildings
where they're similar enough especially
in their colour schemes to be linked and
sort of represent these two sides of the
planet while at the same time they're
different enough to be two separate
buildings with a different style which I
find very interesting actually and also
something that I just had to do with
this building is I wanted to keep it
quite simple because I wasn't really
sure how to really film this thing I
wasn't sure if I was going to film stuff
upside down or if I was going to you
know film it the regular way and then
put it upside down in post-processing
but in any case it's a lot harder to
find good camera angles and to see what
a building looks like if you're building
it upside down because usually you can
kind of get an idea of what a building
looks like when you're building it and
like every now and then you just take a
bit of distance as if you're painting
and painting to see what the building
actually looks like and it is that kind
of process but with an
sign down building it's super hard to
know what it looks like from the coaster
itself especially since I didn't want to
break up the time-lapse with too many
POVs because that's annoying cutting
work and had to and the time-lapse here
and there for that but um in the end I
didn't really have much of an idea of
what this was going to look like
basically I was happily building away at
this thing with a general idea of what I
wanted it to look like but it's very
hard to tell what a building is actually
gonna be when you're building it upside
down and you can't rotate the camera
speaking of which by the way I will show
later on in this video the way that I
got many of the camera shots which are
upside down is that they were either put
upside down in the editing process but
for many of them I actually made a
little rollercoaster that would go
upside down and put that rollercoaster
right next to where I wanted to have my
camera shot so that I would have an
in-game upside down camera shot so I
would know exactly what it was going to
look like and could even tilt the camera
a bit stuff like that which is stuff
that you can't do in planet coaster and
that's definitely something that I might
do later on so I'll show you later on
how I did that but those were really my
only methods of having any kind of
preview of what this building was going
to look like and most of this was just
pretty much winging it there was
definitely some inspiration in this
building though from any kind of
real-life building it's mostly inspired
by a noise one Stein castle in Germany
which sounds ridiculous because if you
know the car so it's actually the
console that inspired the Disney console
it's an enormous building and it's
definitely not what I'm getting at here
but the shape is somewhat different and
it definitely has a similar style and
similar neo-gothic kind of elements so
it's it's inspired by it's just a lot
simpler with less towers I wanted to
keep this very simple and just like the
bottom Tower which I have have one sort
of iconic Tower which juts out from the
planets without making the building too
large and too much dwarfing the rest of
the planet so pretty much all of the
work on the building itself is done at
this point and
wanted to do next is use all of these
rocks on the bottom to blend in the
building a little bit with the
surroundings these rocks are also quite
useful because they maintain the shape
of the planet while at the same time
giving it some detail and something to
look at while you're riding the coaster
I didn't want to fill up the planet with
too much foliage since it would just
completely obstruct the view or the
general shape of the planet really if I
put a lot of trees on it you know you
would have these enormous tree sticking
out from the planet which are almost
larger than the planet itself so I ended
up having a lot of much more empty spots
and some areas which are more filled up
and blended in with all of this book
working smaller bushes in a very similar
way as I did that with Mjolnir actually
I used many of the same pieces that I
used for my honor in the foliage for
this build you might notice by the way
that there are all these floating lights
and that the building is extremely lit
up and I don't know why I haven't talked
about that yet because it's glaringly
obvious that all of that stuff is there
the reason why I put all of those lights
in the first place is because I wanted
to have a good view of what this
building would look like I started
building the building in nighttime with
the lights to have clear view but then I
realized that even in daytime these
lights would still work because the
planet is so huge and the shadow it
casts right underneath it apparently is
so dark that the game says all right
you're allowed to have lights over here
so I could actually light up the
building and this was basically even in
daytime I did this to get an idea of
what it would look like because even in
daytime if I remove those lights the the
shadow from the planet would be so large
that it would be barely possible to see
any of the details on the building
itself and this is also something I
haven't done before but I definitely say
having some working lights on whatever
area you're building if it's very dark
is actually something that it's super
handy so just having some very temperate
kind of what are they the area lights as
well as the floodlights can actually be
super handy if you want to get a better
idea of the things that you're building
so here I'm filling in the foliage of
the planet and at first I did try to do
it as much as I could with some of these
larger
but you can already kind of see the
entire shape of the planet deforming
like all the trees are sticking out in
that weird sense and you can't really
tell that it's a planet anymore and
that's something that I wanted to avoid
in the end so I started sinking in these
trees more and more into the ground as I
moved later during the bill that was
just the cuts in the time maps and I
think that's also one of the cuts where
I started fine-tuning the foliage a
little bit because I wanted to find a
balance between having enough foliage to
make it look as if it's a small planet
with a forest while also not having too
many trees that it would just completely
deform the entire shape of the planet
and just make the planet itself
invisible so there are not that many
trees many of them are just some of the
very small variants that we have and
they're often also synched or sunken
into the planet just to make sure that
you know it doesn't really obstruct the
view in too many ways in the planet
doesn't end up looking like a weird
anomaly of different trees because I was
kind of afraid of that happening and so
more or less all of the foliage kind of
follows the same patterns putting down
the rocks first then just decorating
those rocks with some of the smaller
shrubbery including I think it's the
jungle bush and then we have like that
the desert grass kind of stuff where I'm
still not sure of what exactly it is but
some of that does it cross to give some
3d cross texture in there and after that
is pretty much where I started doing the
the bigger bushes and the trees for
which I just took a lot of different
things what is kind of interesting
though is some of the Terra painting the
idea here because it's very subtle but
there is Terra painting all over this
entire thing not just grass because I
think you can actually mix a super light
sandy texture and a super light soil
texture all over the planet to create
different shades of grass so as you can
see you've got like some lighter areas
some darker areas which makes it all
look a little bit more natural and
interesting and especially with the path
mixing the sand together with some of
the soil and rocky textures actually
resulted in a very rough kind of sandy
path texture almost like one of these
shale pots i don't know how common they
are anywhere else but especially over
here in the netherlands there are many
parts which are not just made of sand
but many shells and stuff throughout it
which are very like coarse and rough
kind of texture for a pop i suppose it's
a little bit gravelly as well that's
what I was going for anyway
in general also it's not much of an
actual path behind just the the fact
that it looks like a path because it's
not technically a part I just had to do
it with terraforming because the game
wouldn't allow me to have a path run
around a sphere like this it's a little
bit too steep to actually have an
in-game path over there I believe and
besides it's not actually a functional
path it just leads from the exits into
the entrance so I guess the ride never
ends and even if you were able to put
some guests on this planet like
literally the only thing that I could do
is leave the coaster only to go right
back into the coaster again it's it's
mr. bones wild ride in disguise
seriously so on the back here and this
was stupid because there's like shadow
all over the bank I hate this place
seriously you might notice in the actual
video of the coaster that I didn't
feature any shots of the back side at
all because it's very poorly lit but
it's not dark enough to allow me to
place lights over here so basically you
don't see anything which is kind of
unfortunate I do like the way that the
coaster is laid out though because
especially these helixes at the end I
found for me were always the biggest
mindfuck because we've got these helixes
and the airtime heroes and it looks as
if your uprights but then all of a
sudden after the airtime here you run
into this brake run launch each section
and you're suddenly back into the
station and it's it's so weird but
that's basically the back side I was
happy to get that over with because I
wanted to move into some of the
detailing now this was very subtle and
these were some touches that you almost
miss when you don't pay a lot of
attention during the POV but I wanted to
put a lot of elements around the entire
planet which have to be standing upright
and basically put them in the same
direction as the planet itself so we
have like wagons and barrels and ten
and that kind of stuff to make it look
when you're on the coaster as if you are
not horizontal or I mean as if you're
not like upside down or banks but as if
you're really next to the ground which
is I don't know a small touch to make it
look as if this planet actually has
gravity of its own which was sometimes
quite tricky especially with some of
these lights since everything has to
point toward the center of the planet
and especially if you don't have a
section of like bare ground to perfectly
Orient's your object to the center of
the planet or if you're placing a
blueprint like with many of these lights
it can be quite hard to have them go
into the exact direction that you're
looking for so some of these things
might not be perfectly placed it just
took a bit of trial and error to do them
but generally speaking they should be
just about looking as if there's actual
gravity on the planet and this is also
interesting decided the lighting of the
planets during daytime because it
doesn't really matter whether it's
daytime or not and actually it does
because I would record the coaster in
daytime but for the lighting itself it
didn't actually matter whether it was
night or not for doing the lighting
since the lower side of the planets is
dark anyway and this kind of gives you
that super weird looking thing where
during daytime right now the bottom part
of the castle is lit up
even though it's daytime and I don't
know that just felt super weird so there
is something that I had to do about that
and that's place this planet in space
and that's what we're gonna do right now
so I made a giant blue screen and this
is basically how I did it I had this
blue screen in the background for the
entire recording process and in editing
I just chroma keyed all of the blue out
there this is also the reason why there
is no blue on the planet itself and that
basically made the entire surrounding
look like space but that also allowed me
to put some space images in there and if
you look very closely actually during
the video you can find that in the
second cinematic shots after the POV on
right of the coaster you can actually
see stars poking through
the roof of the the bottom castle which
was definitely a mistake and that kind
of gave my entire tactical way and some
people did see those stars there that
basically shows that you know all of the
black is actually transparent and I just
put all of those star backgrounds in the
editing process and this is basically
when the blue screen is almost finished
and there is almost an entire huge blue
box around the entire coaster making
sure that there's nothing poking through
and that in editing I could make this
look as if its face there was only one
problem which was quite challenging to
overcome and that is that I needed some
natural lights to come in to actually
light up this planet in a realistic way
so what I did is I just finished the the
blue box of space and left that job for
a later time and I decided to make a gap
in the roof just large enough for the
Sun to light up the entire planet itself
and also shaped in more or less the
shape of this Sun or of a star because I
would imagine that this would be in
different galaxies where small planets
like this exist I don't know that
doesn't make sense but at least you know
at least some kind of light source so I
decided to make this into a bit of an
oval shape since it's 1 p.m. when I
decided to record this which means that
the Sun isn't entirely at its highest
point and it's a little bit diagonally
way so this is actually an oval shape
which because it's kind of an amorphous
turns into a circle from the perspective
of the unwind itself which is perfect
and gives just a light source for the
planet itself but doesn't actually light
up much of the background beyond that so
that was just what I was looking for so
with that natural light source in the
last thing that I wanted to do is make
the stars the stars in the final video
are actually a mixture of in-game stars
and backgrounds that I put in afterwards
the backgrounds that I put in afterwards
were just kind of to give it a bit more
color and like some subtle nebulas and
stuff like that in the space background
but these in-game stars were most
important for the POV
and also gave a bit of a sense of a 3d
space into all of the shots as well and
I'm actually really happy with how these
in-game stories in the end blended in
with some of the actual stars that I put
in with the backgrounds so it's there's
like multiple methods I use the blue
screen to make sure that I could make an
entire pitch-black space around the
coaster I also use that blue screen to
make sure I could put my own custom
space well not really custom they were
just from like Google Images and like
royalty free websites but put my own
space backgrounds in there to make it
look as if it's space and finally I put
these little lights in here to make it
look as if there are actually stars
anyway that's it for the time lapse
let's go in game for a minute to see
what it actually looked like all right
so we're in game now I have the
beautiful beautiful frame rate of 9 fps
and interesting little fact the blue
screen actually consists of over 50,000
objects which is my personal record
within a single building it's pretty
interesting it's also what's killing my
frame rate at the moment so I'll close
that thing and give my game a few
seconds to actually process me closing
that tab because it usually likes to go
crazy when it does this but that aside
it actually runs pretty decent as long
as you're not selecting the building or
accidentally miss clicking on the
background which happened quite a few
times and which is super annoying the
frame rate is actually about 28 fps so
it's it's not that bad and this is
basically what the planet looks like
in-game as you get it with the entire
blue screen and all of the stars and
everything in the background now what
you immediately notice especially as you
come like in the back here is the big
blue giants kind of star which looks a
bit like a misshapen circle which is
actually a weird oval shape that I had
to do to get in some of the natural
sunlight this is what it looks like from
the outside but also there is a bit of a
lights being casted on the background
over here this was pretty much something
that I couldn't get rid of because I did
have to make the lights that's coming
out of this hall over here a little bit
wider than
what we have as the planet itself so
it's definitely costing a bit on the
ground here I had to chroma key change
the settings
whenever the this thing over here was
visible from the coaster itself but that
one more than fine usually it's only a
little bit visible at some points during
the POV actually only during one point I
think and the hall itself
I just left in the sky figuring that's
you know the only light source that we
have that might as well be the local
star of whatever galaxy this is in so if
I actually run the coaster this is what
it looks like as you can actually see it
running with the weird blue background
it's quite fast I would say by the way
that this is not something that I would
recommend running whatsoever one thing
which I always liked about this is that
it seems as though these curves actually
banking inward where in reality that's
religious the illusion of the planet
around it making you think as though
these curves actually properly banks
because these curves are banked outward
and they're super fast like this is the
one thing that you would never want to
do on an actual real life coaster
surprisingly this thing has pretty good
stats actually which blowed my mind
because it shouldn't have it should be
pretty much lethal it's got an
excitement rating of over nine sure it's
got a fear of 8.2 but in game there
would probably be some people who are
Daredevils and willing to write this
thing which by the way is something that
I wouldn't actually recommend doing
especially with some of the lateral
g-forces that you have on the bottom of
the planet because in the end all of the
acceleration is still downwards and down
into the ground which is underneath
right here and because of that we have
like G's of six point eight which is far
above what's actually recommended and
especially the lateral G's which is six
point two you don't want lateral G's to
be very high its own six point two is
absolutely ridiculous
if would not recommend you write this
thing whatsoever I am pretty sure this
would be the airtime or at least the
upwards acceleration would be the
airtime and that's something that
you don't want to have those kinds of
g-forces this is enough to cause
blackouts for people or at least cause
your blood to do things which it
shouldn't be doing especially for such
long periods of time so don't ride this
coaster by the way it might look fine
and any on its little planet but it
actually doesn't work all that well but
yeah the quirks of the layout aside this
is basically what it looks and this is
how it works it's actually quite simple
now if I take away the planet and this
is very interesting as well because I
have a blueprints of the coaster as it's
not within the planet so if I take away
the planet
it actually looks very interesting let
me see for a second where it actually
was all right there we go this is
basically what the coaster looks like
without the planets surrounding it and
right now it doesn't actually even still
look like that much but basically if you
turn on all of the supports you can very
easily tell why many parts of this
layout it should not be condoned
whatsoever
almost selected everything there all
right let's turn on the supports because
especially on some of the lower parts of
the track over here for instance it's
pulling you at over a hundred kilometers
an hour into a curve which is pink
outward like this going upside down and
coming back on the other side with more
lateral G's for everyone's enjoyment and
probably death so no I would not
recommend this thing whatsoever it's
it's it's a death coaster basically if
anybody remembers them from roller
coaster cone one where you would build
lovely death traps that would kill all
the guests this is basically such a
thing but then that's also what I kind
of liked about it it only really works
in the entire context of the planet
which we have over here and then aside
it's just a weird coaster on a
terraforming ball surrounded by blue
walls and a hole in the ceiling so this
is basically it thank you guys for
watching this series you can actually
check out the coaster on the workshop I
will put up a link with the blue-screen
version as well though I don't think
many people are too interested in that I
think it's makes a bit more sense to
have the version without the blue screen
so I'll also have a
blue-screen less regular version of the
planet up on the workshop so you can
download it for yourself and yeah that
was basically it
hope you guys enjoyed and I'll see you
in the next project